[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
hey there car gamers i'm the lucky
carter and this is another pack opening
video today i am opening catch monsters
packs and digging for that epic shiny
transcend dog
and here i'll add some crazy vfx with
lightning bolts or something
okay ladies and gentlemen i am about to
open my first pack
feeling good about this one
feeling real good
what do we got here
okay
and our first rare is
a
birch kin
not exactly a viable competitive card
but hey
it's a pretty one
all right
next pack feeling even better about this
one
i gotta say these cards are feeling
extra silky today
i mean
they're so smooth
not sure what they're doing down there
at the uh the card factory but um these
are feeling good in my hands
okay
let's see what we got here
some
jank cards
maybe a few additions to my draft cube
we'll see
and our rare for this pack is
bam dog
not exactly riveting so far but we have
many packs to go
next pack here we come
just cut out this part
hey there card gamers i'm the lucky
carter and this is a vintage pack
opening video today i'm opening a few
super rare old packs i snagged at a
garage sale i've got four packs of
inscription
you would not believe the deal i got on
these now not all of you will even
remember this game i'm barely old enough
to have seen these going around in my
childhood
for whatever reason they only did one
set of these cards and then stopped
printing them
there's not a huge market for them
anymore but
at the rate i got them for there's not
really much to lose
that being said
a foil mantis god goes for a couple
hundred bucks so
fingers crossed
really cool art on these
definitely stands the test of time
and our rare for this pack is
blue mage
cool looking card but not going to be
worth very much
all right
let's see what we got going on in the
second pack
ah
uh
this pack has been opened
and
resealed
hope no one snuck the rare out of it
that would suck
come on people honestly who opens and
reseals
[Music]
yeah
there's a set of coordinates on this
card
looks like they were
drawn on with a pen
49 degrees north 123 degrees west
i think
i'd have to check but i think that's
pretty nearby
all right you guys
i'm out here
living my best life
got my trusty headlamp
and shovel
always come prepared kids
all right
there we go
yeah
okay
getting close
okay
okay
getting close
i think
assuming there is
a thing
to get close to
this very well may be
a
massive
waste
all right
that's why
you always bring
an extra battery boys and girls
every time
they got to come prepared
okay
all right
this is it
and now
we dig
i give a 75 chance it's a rock
but
only one way to find out
what the [ __ ]
is that
oh my god you guys i can't believe it
there's actually something here
ah
what guys
are you seeing this
i'm uh
i'm a little confused
who even has a floppy disk drive anymore
okay 11 bucks
cheaper than a foil steep ball willy
all right fine
all right fine
who even has a floppy disk drive anymore
okay 11 bucks
cheaper than a foil steam ball willy
all right fine
wow great video
okay
time to figure out what's on this thing
so
so
you